das schock video ein polizist wird mit
gestrecktem bein total niedergetreten
das video hat ganz deutschland
schockiert ja und welches ausmaß für was
spricht dieses video welches ausmaß an
gewalt gibt es mittlerweile für unsere
einsatzkräfte lebensretter
mir ist jetzt der bundesvorsitzende der
deutschen feuerwerke schöpfwerk schafft
siegfried maier zugeschaltet guten tag
herr meier
sie haben das video gerade auch gesehen
was geht da in ihnen vor wenn sie das
sehen die bilder sieht dann kommen wir
eigentlich nur eins bekommen angst
bekommen um das eigene leben rund um das
leben der kolleginnen und kollegen die
täglich draußen helfen
was haben sie denn persönlich schon in
ihrer laufbahn ihrer karriere erlebt
oder erleben müssen vielleicht sogar
jeder von uns von unseren kolleginnen
und kollegen erlebt viele dinge ich
selbst seit 1995 im rettungsdienst und
berufsfeuerwehr tätig gewesen
mir ist auch schon mal ein patient an
den hals gegangen und habe mir die luft
aus was hat sich denn im vergleich zu
früher geändert war das früher anders
oder sind heute die leute einfach
gewaltbereiter ich denke die die
menschen die gesellschaft ist enthemmter
dieses enthemmt sein da verschieben sich
die grenzen das war es früher nicht mehr
normal ist heute normal das wird von den
kolleginnen kollegen aus der straßen
oder von der straße berichtet die
beleidigungen die wir früher erlebt
haben das war ein zwei mal drei mal im
monat
heute erlebe die kolleginnen kollegen
das täglich und wie gesagt die grenze
geht nach oben ein
ein angriff für eine tätigkeit erlebten
war heute ein zwei mal die woche und das
ist nicht tolerierbar
haben sie denn angst wenn sie gerade
sagen dass man das ein- bis zweimal die
woche erlebt haben sie angst wenn sie
zum einsatz gerufen werden
das muss man differenziert betrachten
wenn man zu einem einsatz fährt dann
spürt man erstmal keine angst mal erlebt
oder mal überlegt hinterher und erlebt
dann hinterher
die angst einsatz im einsatz angst das
würde leben und das ist nicht gut und
das verdrängen viele problematisch wird
hinterher
im vorgespräch hatten sie gesagt dass
sie wirklich auch angst haben dass man
heutzutage als rettungs vertretungskraft
erschossen oder so erstochen wird und
eben nicht mehr nur beleidigt wird
es ist wichtig das wird immer wieder
berichtet die kolleginnen und kollegen
machen sich natürlich gedanken um
hinterher oder vor den einsätzen äußern
solche gedanken dass gipfel ja wenn man
zurückdenkt an der berichterstattung aus
gera das gipfelt darin dass man angst
hat wenn man im feuer steht ihr sprechen
von im feuer stehen mit wasser am rohr
wasser ist für uns unsere
lebensversicherung in gera ist es
passiert das bei einem innenangriff den
kolleginnen und kollegen das wasser
draußen am hydranten abgedreht wurde und
somit waren nicht nur in akuter
lebensgefahr sondern wir kommen sogar
von versuchtem mord sprechen und was
fordern sie konkret wie könnte das
verbessert werden die situation
die situation momentan könnte besser
werden für unsere kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn man natürlich so was wie
in stuttgart jetzt passiert ist nicht
nur verfolgt sondern auch verwirrtheit
und auch darüber berichtet das würde
unseren kolleginnen kollegen sicherheit
geben dass so was nicht im sande
verläuft was jetzt notwendig ist ist
eine diskussion um schutzwesten um body
camps schutzwesten fordern wir seit zwei
jahren dass die groß angelegt werden
dass kolleginnen und kollegen wenn sie
bestimmte einsatzlagen geht wie karneval
die silvester dass man diese auf diese
westen zurückgreifen kann
und soeben eine passive und aktive
sicherheit gegeben wird danke schön herr
meier für das gespräch und ihnen alles
gute